your medical records used to look like
this
now 80% are digital making your health
information easier for people and
businesses to access let's say this is
your electronic health record it
contains information on your medical
history diagnoses prescriptions and lots
more you might not expect text giants
like Amazon and Apple to be getting
involved with your electronic health
records but they are along with smaller
tech companies like zelf and they're
starting to use them to grow new
businesses here's how three companies
are using our health data right now and
how they can dive deeper into our
medical data in the future let's start
with zelf they're a Seattle based
startup that recently developed an
application that's embedded in a
patient's electronic health record
here's how it works
medical professionals at hospitals that
use zelf create lists of products they
think could be useful for their patients
for example they might come up with 30
different products or services that
could be useful for any of their
pregnant patients these can include
everything from services like
instructional videos and newsletters to
products like maternity belts
compression socks and body pillows then
zelf adds these lists into their system
if a doctor has a pregnant patient they
can pull up the recommended list of
products and services for pregnant
people while looking at that patient's
medical record the doctor then goes
through that list and selects which
products and services they actually want
to recommend to their pregnant patient
from there the doctor sends their
patient a digital shopping list if the
patient clicks on a product they're
directed to one of Szell's 30 vendor
sites which include Amazon baby scripts
and lifts and given the option to buy
some privacy experts worry that certain
zelf vendors can see when a patient
purchased a product through zelf and
therefore through their electronic
health record in theory it could boost
adherence to physician recommendations
which is a huge challenge in the US
healthcare system on the other side
there are real worries about what type
of
Meishan Amazon in particular is getting
access to so from what I understand is
that when patient clicks on that self
app and is taken to Amazon the data is
quoted as self data which means that
Amazon likely knows that you purchase
those products through your electronic
health record next up is Amazon in
addition to the tech giant's connection
to zelf it started selling its own
software that uses artificial
intelligence to mine patients electronic
health records it's called Amazon
comprehend medical and it's part of the
company's cloud computing service the
software is sold to hospitals
pharmaceutical companies researchers and
other healthcare providers this helps
doctors and researchers identify trends
that humans may not notice here's how it
works
hospitals and other users upload
portions of the patient's medical data
to Amazon Web Services the software then
analyzes the data and is then presented
to doctors in the form of something
similar to an Excel spreadsheet by using
keywords doctors can sift through tons
of patient's data to find strong
candidates for research studies if
they're looking for people with melanoma
who also have a family history of cancer
they can do this in seconds where it
used to take hours while studies
acknowledge the potential benefits of
electronic health records in that they
could help researchers find cures for
diseases they also stress the potential
for inaccuracies noting coding problems
or doctors entering wrong information I
think it's also very important to be
transparent around the limitations of
big data and machine learning and
natural language processing and other
types of AI that we're using to analyze
the data and so right now there are
serious concerns about the quality of
data so for example my OBGYN electronic
health record said I was male and I was
pregnant at the time
finally Apple is using the iPhones
health app to make medical records
easier to access the health records
feature is located in the app and it
imports your medical information
directly from your health care provider
this includes everything from
information on allergies immunizations
lab results medications and even vitals
there are already more than 150
participating healthcare institutions
the idea is to give an American iPhone
user the ability to pull up their
medical record on their phone and
present it to a doctor anywhere in the
world the move by Apple is just one
example of how its recently made inroads
into healthcare in 2016 the company
added a feature to the health app that
allows users to sign up to be an organ
donor and earlier this year Apple watch
added a new electrical heart sensor
feature which has been cleared by the
FDA so its companies continue to use our
electronic health records what does this
mean for our privacy Amazon and Apple
say they can't use or view the
information they also say it's encrypted
which helps prevent our health records
from getting hacked in addition HIPAA
has security rules that protect
individuals electronic health
information making our medical records
some of the most difficult personal data
to access in spite of this dr. Dudley
Adams a data use expert doesn't think
this is enough no encryption is perfect
all it takes is time to eventually get
through the encryption the thing people
are most worried about about having
their health records Act is that then
people will sell that information to
insurance companies or employers so that
they can avoid sick people and that
hacking can mean that suddenly your
private information makes you
unemployable or uninsurable privacy
experts also stress the need for
openness as companies move deeper into
our electronic health records so the
more that the companies can be
transparent about these things the less
the black boxes and perhaps more
appropriate trust we can build in the
system so whether or not privacy
concerns outweigh the potential research
benefits one thing's for sure this is
just the beginning of companies tapping
into our health data there's gonna be so
much opportunity to make money because
there's so much waste it's three
trillion dollars are spent on health
care every year